je dis que vous avez rencontré tout le
conseil des ministres s'est encore se
rencontrer cette semaine pour préparer
le retour en chambre discours du trône
on avait l'impression cours des derniers
mois qui avaient beaucoup beaucoup
d'attentes face à ce discours du trône
le biais de grands projets or cette
semaine on aurait dit que vous reculiez
un peu ce cas mais on a branché le
gouvernement canadien dans la réalité
que vivent les canadiens présentement et
depuis plusieurs mois donc c'est un
discours du trône qui est super
important pour voir la suite mais faut
aussi voir ce qui se passe présentement
s'assurer que la relance dont on parle
beaucoup et qu'on espère beaucoup
souhaite une relance il soit aussi
sécuritaire parce que pour qu'il y ait
un volant ça prend confiance dans la
population prend confiance pour les
entrepreneurs et les travailleurs et on
est dans un climat qui est encore un
climat de kobe 19 kimo d'orge la santé
des canadiens
moi je la sens beaucoup ressent beaucoup
partout ce soit les les familles les
faire d'ailleurs les entreprises les
années évidemment et cette confiance des
faucons sud et à la maintenir parce
qu'on voit émerger de cette crise à la
fois d'un point de vue social économique
et sanitaire qu'on aurait aimé ça ça
vous dit mais sur ce que vous pouvez
faire les grands chantiers les grands
projets vous les mettez un peu sur la
glace mais c'est un peu comme dans un
tunnel
le tunnel on le perd il fait noir mais
on a besoin de voir la lumière au bout
pour s'encourager pour s'éclairer sur ce
qui s'en vient mais dans un tunnel pour
éviter s'enfarger faut regarder en avant
enfin gardez le regarde devant nos nos
pieds puis tout en étant éclairé
encouragé par la lumière au bout donc
c'est la stratégie de dire qu'on voit
toujours être là pour aider les
canadiens pour passer à travers les
preuves que l'on vit tous collectivement
et qu'on a de grandes ambitions pour la
suite
les inquiétudes dont on parle et semble
être suscitée par la crainte d'une
deuxième vague ont volé chef remontée
vous les voyez aussi à quel moment est
ce que vous pouvez vous permettre d'être
ambitieux mais on est déjà très
ambitieux et ambitieux en termes de
maintenir de protéger et de préserver le
tissu économique et le moment est ce que
veut aller au delà de ça parce qu'au
départ c'était l'art fond des filets
sociaux la relance verte les grands
chantiers on est plus lol oui on est
donc certainement là on est là en terme
de
de vision et d'ambition pour l'avenir
mais on voit ce qui se passe au canada
et au québec en particulier depuis
quelques semaines la situation est
critique
donc dans ce contexte qui est
malheureusement celui qu'on vit
maintenant où on doit maintenir la santé
la sécurité des gens baissent et un
contexte qui nous oblige comme
gouvernement canadien a continué de
maintenir notre focus sur une relance
sécuritaire pour tous qu'est ce qui va
rester dans discours du trône alors vous
avez parlé des aînés vous avez parlé
vous parlez des femmes des familles
qu'est ce qui se passe que vous pouvez
leur offrir dans ce contexte heures mais
un agenda aussi tourné vers l'avenir la
lumière au bout du tunnel
on sait qu'on est parti d'une situation
très forte au canada avant la crise on
avait une des meilleures économies en
termes de croissance
un des bilans fiscaux les plus solides
on avait du développement économique et
de se tourner de plus en plus vers le
développement durable
on avait une société qui était forte et
solidaire non pas du moment difficile et
l'on n'est plus lol tout à fait mais on
sait qu'on peut y retourner parce que
les bases sur lesquelles les parties
étaient solides et sur les bases sur
lesquelles on pourra lancer la relance
après la corvée des camps aussi
consacrons cette fin là vont aussi être
très solide mais la solidité de cette
base n'est pas quelque chose de garantie
elle doit faire partie de l'agenda du
gouvernement canadien donc il faut que
le gouvernement entendait continuer à
protéger les entreprises les
travailleurs pour qu'il y ait une base
solide sur laquelle a progressé par la
suite
monsieur jusque là où vous êtes vous
êtes vous êtes au sein d'un gouvernement
minoritaire qui est peut-être devant une
deuxième vague à quel point ce que vous
avez de la marge de manoeuvre j'écoute
vos intentions ça me semble tout à fait
loi mais j'ai pas l'impression vous avez
la marge de manoeuvre pour le faire mais
on ne la marge de manoeuvre fiscale on
ne la volonté politique de le faire et
je pense que les partis d'opposition
sont aussi comme moi branché sur la
réalité de leurs citoyens
moi dans ma circonscription québec je
sais ce dont parlent les gens ils
veulent s'assurer qu'ils soient en santé
et en sécurité il veut aussi s'assurer
que à travers la crise le tissu
économique soit maintenue nous reparlons
la marge de manoeuvre fiscale parce que
vous lirez abordés on évalue le déficit
à l'heure actuelle à 343 milliards de
dollars à peu près à quel point est-ce
que vous pouvez dépenser encore quelle
est votre marge de manoeuvre on arrête
tout
mais le mot-clé ses responsabilités
responsabilité fiscale parce
qu'évidemment on veut maintenir la force
spéciale du gouvernement canadien
certainement par rapport aux autres pays
du g7
on note encore au canada par rapport à
d'autres pays du g7
une situation fiscale qui est très
solide et très enviable ceci étant dit
on a aussi la responsabilité économique
parce que si on veut avoir la capacité
de maintenir cette force jusqu'à ça nous
prend aussi d'économie qui soit solide
allez en austérité se serait par exemple
se déplacer d'une récession qui étaient
mauvaises avec une dépression qui une
récession qui toujours sur de nombreuses
années et qui auraient des conséquences
car elle est en même temps vous pouvez
pas dépenser à tout vent comme ça et
s'arrête à manier la responsabilité elle
arrête à quel montant dans votre bain on
ne dépense pas à tout vent on dépense
sur des choses qui sont importantes pour
le rock ce que limite vous le président
du conseil du trésor
ce qu'on y met tous on this l'on peut
plus aller au de l'action il ya
effectivement une limite ne veut
certainement jamais y arriver c'est quoi
il n'y arrivera pas si on investit comme
on doit le faire dans la préservation du
tissu économique et social du pays
deux éléments que je vais aborder avec
vous un rapidement termine à la
frontière américaine la frontière entre
le canada les etats-unis on a renouvelé
la fermeture ou aux déplacements non
essentiels jusqu'au 21 octobre
est ce que vous envisagez que cette
frontière la voirie ouvrir d'ici la fin
de l'année
mais la question vient de l'énoncé
suivant la situation aux états unis est
cinquante fois pire en matière de cas de
kobe 19 qu'au canada
même si on a juste pour la population
qui différentes c'est cinq fois plus
graves ou ceux de la frontière que seul
et au canada donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent et reconnaître comme
la plupart des américains le font aussi
qu'au canada nous avons la charge
jusqu'à maintenant en raison d'une plus
grande discipline et d'une plus grande
clarté des messages à part des
gouvernements de vivre une situation qui
est moins grave en matière sanitaire et
donc moins grave en matière économique
est ce que vous allez présenter mercredi
vous êtes confiant de pouvoir obtenir
l'appui d'au moins un parti d'opposition
ben nous on ne veut ni austérité ni
élections et le pense que les canadiens
ne veulent pas d'élections non plus mais
comme vous l'avez très bien risée
monsieur thibault nous sommes le
gouvernement minoritaire se sont tous
partis d'opposition de décider s'ils
veulent continuer de nous appuyer pour
appuyer les canadiens mais c'était à eux
de faire leur choix nous notre choix
c'est de focaliser sur les intérêts des
canadiens
maintenant pour s'assurer qu'on passe
plus fort et tous ensemble à travers
cette liste jacques duclos merci
beaucoup merci à vous